الذي جرى في مخيم جنين صباح هذا اليوم
وفقا لروايه شهود عيان فان قوته من
المستعربين وهم قوه عسكريه تتخفى بالزي
المدني دخلت المخيم صباحا في مركبه لبيع
الالبان ثم تبيعتها قوه الاحتلال بعد نشر
القناصه في اكثر من مكان بهدف تامين دخول
القوات الاسرائيليه ثم بدات الاشتباكات في
اكثر من محور من مخيم جنين توغلت قوات
الاحتلال الى داخله وقالت فصائل المقاومه
ان مقاتلها اشتبكوا مع قوه الاحتلال
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دفعت بتعزيزات
اضافيه وصلت عبر حاجز الجلمه
واغلقت جميع مداخل المخيم وقطعت الكهرباء
بالكامل
طبعا الروايه الاسرائيليه الرسميه تذكر ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وجهاز الامن العام
والشرطه الحدود الاسرائيليه وقوات شرطه
اليمام كلها هؤلاء نفذوا عمليه وسط المخيم
وسط مخيم جنين وذلك بهدف اعتقال خليه
تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه وانا
اشتباكات الجرد وتم تحييد ثلاثه منهم وفقا
لتعبير الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذا وقد شيع سكانه مدينه جنين ومخيمها عدد
من الشهداء الذين سقطوا خلال العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم